Mortal Kombat
Neri shit Mortal Kombat is not about
death but rather the preservation of
life that's what you guys paid to see
right two guys beating each other until
15 orphans recover from cancer these
monks have so much inner peace it takes
them a good 20 seconds to sort of react
to this giant as lightning storm that's
all it takes to knock this tower down
and there's no fucking way it stayed
erect for this long and I intentionally
use the word erect because these towers
all look like giant penises also the
special effects were downgraded to good
for a student film during production
movies fireballs remind me less of 90s
era Mortal Kombat and more of 1985 NES
Super Mario Billy Madison and the first
Mortal Kombat aren't beneath Bridget
Wilson but the sequel definitely is a
whole bunch of those ninjas just fell
out of the sky yet everyone here is
slowly walking around not fighting out
world apparently has a pleather store
for the discerning forearm consumer yeah
was created in six days so too shall it
be destroyed wait it choked on just
confirm the creation story in Genesis if
so it seems like now it'd be a really
good time for God to show up with some
smiting also this guy does the worst
David Byrne impression I've ever heard I
thought our victory in Mortal Kombat
closed those photos what closes can also
open a gun this must be another one of
those simple rules of mortal combat that
don't get mentioned until it's too
polite this movie was made for about 50
bucks right I'm pretty sure the camera
was pointed at a green screen when they
had to get somebody out of bed at 4:00
a.m. who saw someone turn on a camera
once after successfully turning it on
they said now just do stuff in front of
it as long as I have the power Conn you
will never rule this world as long as
the portrait remains open your world
becomes my world it only took them three
minutes to undo what they accomplished
in the last movie just goes to show you
can accomplish anything you want in
absolutely no time if you don't burden
yourself with explaining why I know this
is supposed to look like ancient ruins
but based on how quickly everything is
crumbling to the ground this structure
was probably built in 1994 the clouds in
the background are moving but the still
photograph of minions in the background
sure aren't I hope these fight scenes
aren't all gonna be 90% jumping the
director just told Shao Khan to fall
down a few times and they would throw
them in where it seemed appropriate
master master here have a whip that
should help you against a guy who used
the power of lightning fine uh would she
get up there in the middle of their
fight it's too bad the movie forgot to
include life bars made
they could have avoided a Lisa little
confusion Brayton decides that now is
the correct time to use his Darth
Sidious finger instead of all the other
times in the last five minutes where
would have been more useful also rating
because earth does not bend to the will
of tyrants I don't know where Aidan I
just skimmed through a history book and
I'm gonna have to ask for your sources
on that trade me for Johnny Cage crumb
bomb at my feet Oh aha I could have had
Raiden as my slave but I'd much rather
snap one of your friends necks in
retrospect I should have taken the first
offer but this is more fun haha
all these fighters do an awful lot of
standing when they should be defending
themselves but in all fairness they may
have exceeded the movies budget for
these special effects you would think
that after a certain amount of time
Raiden would develop some type of
defense for getting thrown into a wall
since it's so frequent Johnny Cage is
working real hard to appear dead in six
days you will all bow to me I put a six
day time limit on it yeah I heard that
God created the world in six days thing
but that's not much of a reason all this
does is give our heroes enough time to
figure out how to defeat Shao Kahn
naya-a gong the bad guys with the powers
left for no reason and left there
obviously unequipped minions to handle
people who just want a Mortal Kombat a
day I go how far away is that army of
ninjas they seem to have plenty of time
to mosey away so they must be at the
other end of the penis ruins your planet
and our world have begun to merge into
one realm what the fuck does this mean
when Shao Kahn conquers a planet does it
become part of the out world or
something else going on here
Raiden could just explain this properly
in a similar amount of time but it
happened so fast he may not know what
he's talking about the rules say the
earth is safe for another generation
obviously Kahn has cheated and broken
the rules it's getting to where you
can't trust any evil warlords from
parallel dimensions nowadays I believe
he has resurrected your mother to keep
these portals open indefinitely by
reuniting you with her conne spell will
be broken why would that have any
relationship to the opening and closing
of portals the only connection seems to
be that burying her and resurrecting her
in the earth realm give Shao Kahn access
to the realm but how was he able to
resurrect her if the portals were closed
and based on what Raiden just said it
seems that resurrecting Sindel can only
benefit Raiden in the human's all in all
this makes no sense
enough creighton makes it look like he
did this because he was angry but that's
where they need to go which brings up
the question why isn't there a door
there once inside the Velo sphere you
can travel to anywhere on earth in mere
hours this is also true airplanes there
we go
am I seeing this is this for real also
the designers of the Velo sphere went
with the aqua
hanging instead of some standard chairs
so the passengers could gaze deeply into
each other's eyes at they travel also
how these travel balls know where they
need to go where are we
the interchange rows you're right hard
I'm real glad he asked otherwise who
knows where they would have ended up
also who made these series of tunnels
and why would they leave a spot where
you die if you don't turn the ball at
the right time
also movie doesn't show 10 rec balls and
about 40 skeletons of people who did not
turn at the right time try not to get a
boner that'll take us to Pittsburgh
there he could not be stopped I mean he
offered himself as a sacrifice but I
decided to snap the neck of some asshole
named Johnny Cage instead I am broken
the sacred rules to keep the parcels
open seemed like it was pretty easy to
do the sacred rules seem more like
sacred suggestions do not underestimate
the power of the human spirit I think my
sister has that girl stitched on a
pillow and I'm not going to lose you too
I'm not gonna lose you too cliche all
the ninjas go after katana instead of
helping robot predator fight Liu Kang
also they lean on the standard
one-at-a-time rule allowing katana to
easily defeat them
remember your fight scenes can move as
slowly as you want as long as you
remember to end dramatic sound effects
over the Blues using a lot of energy on
unnecessary flipping simple dodge would
have allowed him to avoid this chest
rocket it's just cannon is so powerful
it caused the bridge to explode in
places where the rocket didn't even hit
it some 0x mark enough to shake the
camera up and down to indicate an
explosion no one will be able to you
killed my older brother so I took his
costume and assumed his warrior name
just call me sub-zero like he never died
okay because legend has it the princess
is the key to stopping Kahn's plot
didn't Kahn's plot involve violating the
sacred rules of the tournament and
everyone is totally shocked it just
happened so this does not qualify as a
legend and certainly not enough time for
subzero jr. here to have enough time to
figure out the curve predicament also
the legend turns out to be a trick
anyway so why create this complicated
backstory about a legend just say you
have an idea and run with it that's all
anyone else is doing you've been
following us has he been following them
didn't they take a magical travel ball
here
Khan reprogram smoke to come after you
instead of me in order to keep you apart
from Queen Sindel did smoke tell
sub-zero Wyatt stop coming after him in
great detail otherwise I'm not sure
where he's getting his Intel oh so
that's how the cover of every late 90s
rap album was made I guess this is
scorpions brother to everybody who dies
as a replacement sibling ready to take
their place because these ruthless
fighters parents believed in large
families also the movie sequel is ready
to play all the hits scorpion versus
sub-zero doesn't make any sense in this
movie
the people who play the game something
to be excited than disappointed about ah
Tommy Lee Jones
I guess Luanne katana aren't helping
subzero defeat scorpion because the
bridge sub-zero is standing on is
probably slippery and there was no way
they could back tuck their way to
victory watch out he's gonna fall into
that projection of a lava flow all right
Lou you just proved that you could have
helped this whole time asshole
oh great martial arts reflexes their
katana scorpion transports himself
through a portal made of jello what's
happened here should prove you alone are
not ready for what's ahead
even though Lou lone is not ready
sub-zero leaves him alone because he's
also an asshole is it like this
everywhere with each other the merger of
the realms grows closer more of the
earth will be destroyed realm mergers
only work by the hour making them no
better than a fry cook at McDonald's was
there not a door she could use now that
they know where Jax was in this
apparently abandoned lab in Hawaii and
why isn't it burned down since we
clearly saw it on fire on the outside
also pretty convenient this guy decided
to get bionic man surgery since the last
time we saw it these guys have
impeccable timing every time one of the
lead characters arrives anywhere in
extermination squad swoops in right at
the same time I can't get you free Jax
alright stand back stand back let's see
what I made
why didn't we start with this wish I had
these babies back in high school
Jax you'd rip your dick off even though
this extermination robot knew he could
use his chest weapon first instead of
engaging in standard hand-to-hand combat
he's still wasted to explosives on
nothing he already blew up the doors
there wasn't anything else in his way
these extermination squad ninjas
remember how to hold their weapons at
the ready but forget about actually
following through I bet this yellow
robot guy is really regretting wasting
those two bombs right now because this
is one of the slowest weapons I've seen
so far
Jax's arms can punch through a concrete
wall but can't manage to cause
significant damage to his opponent's
outer shell oh I guess that supernatural
robot doesn't work against Bionic arms
it was nice of him to just stand there
and let Sonya grab it and flip him
across the room are you kidding me
this is ridiculous even for this movie
if that stuff was that flammable it
would have caught on fire as soon as
these pipes first making it really hard
for her to pick it up I know Sonya blew
it off her hand it should make a path
back to her hand and face burning the
shit out of her hand and face throwing a
hand full of that stuff would have been
way too much trouble where the fuck are
they right now based on the way the shot
is set up they could be falling down an
Alice in Wonderland rabbit hole fire
right now there is no way to know
well taru is half RAM half man half
horse and half alligator making him many
things but most of all an improper
fraction jutsu
make them beg for their lives before you
destroyed them but master I thought for
let know you first off this asshole
asked the same question his father asked
him when he didn't kill Raiden for some
dumb reason second off don't these guys
have orders to kill the people they're
fighting or are they just leading it up
to the minions to decide movie not only
steals the fireballs from Super Mario
but also steals the hammer from Donkey
Kong oh are they preparing for a video
game shared cinematic universe oh god
you are my new general Queen Sindel what
a day for Queen Sindel she's already
Queen being promoted to general one day
they'll turn her into whatever Amidala
was in the Star Wars prequels Liu is
getting attacked by a camera someone
help him who are you Liu is looking for
someone named night wolf and he just
fought a wolf man and is still asking
this question your rates prodigy I've
seen better
that's seen worse - how many fucking
prodigies is Raiden hat and why is he
seen so many does this keep happening
you know I won Mortal Kombat this
asshole sure finds a way to insert that
into a conversation doesn't it the
tournament had rules it did
what were they you think you're ready
Liu Kang but if you were with katana
have been captured night won't seems to
know everything except that Liu and
sub-zero already had this conversation
let's eat Shao Kahn you've got to pass
three tests Jesus Christ to test your
courage and find Jory animality you've
got to put yourself in a dream state why
doesn't this guy kill Khan seems like he
knows all necessary sweet dreams Liu
Kang and with that this important
asshole leaves the movie forever my
heart belongs to another I mean I've
only known her for a few days and we
almost kissed once so I can't mess up a
good thing how can you be true oh God
when I alone I'm too much for you to be
fair shall conduction skills are nowhere
near her level you are even more pure
and faithful than I heard you have
passed the test okay
well that was easy Liu Kang passed two
major tests over the course of a yo
gabba gabba episode time to battle evil
you have passed the test okay what was
the test get on top because she's the
key to all of this if you haven't quite
gotten the katana is the key to all this
just wait about ten minutes I'm sure
someone else will mention she's alive
for now yes if katana is the key to
defeating she'll calm and there doesn't
seem to be any back-up plan why is Shao
Kahn keeping her alive oh this would be
over she was dead right
struggling worm on a hook lends a bigger
catch than a dead one that's a fine
idiom but his goal should be ruling both
the out world and the earth realm not
luring Luke
hang in the gang there to rescue katana
if he runs out the week he could just
killed him whenever he wants
nature's die emerged off the rounds is
almost done I wonder when all the other
people of Earth are doing right now and
I wonder what they think is happening
probably best not to show them though we
don't need to understand the stakes but
it don't mean squat to me I I can't
explain it
Sonia continues to not explain anything
to Jax but talks to him like he should
know what she's talking about she could
at least explain a little bit do it off
camera I don't care just explain
something because you clearly can't use
my imagination you keep talking to me
like that Sonia and I'm a split eye holy
Sonia is a dick she's irritated with Jax
for wanting to know what the hell's
going on if I'm a DA today at least tell
me why nobody told me why Johnny had to
die who does Johnny at least tell him
who Johnny is this fight would have been
a lot shorter if she didn't yell before
attacking katana that racist The Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo Mortal Kombat
edition rent the jacks come from and Jax
beat the everyone got are those computer
graphics either did these assholes land
high up on a cliff if you know where
Sonia and Jax are why not teleport
straight to them instead of landing on
Tuscan Raider country Raiden is walking
through two rows of invisible guys
giving him high-fives right now I have
come to the eternal palace because your
sacred rules have been broken it's the
eternal palace on earth there is this
movie - low-budget to make another set
that looks like a different realm who
lit all these goddamn candles how do the
Elder Gods have a budget for 2.6 million
candles as always bored me you are
granted three questions why are the
Elder Gods just genies why was this
treachery ever allowed we do not control
the Sami gone breaking the rules has
nothing to do with the destiny of man
this is more than just a dodge it's the
wrong cancer Jade surprise attacks
Jackson Sonya which tells me that she
and Liu saw them before him and decided
to hide behind all those rocks waiting
for them but Liu knows what Sonya looks
like so what the cos is all about Kahn's
extermination squad is suddenly medieval
and no longer ninjas and cheap robots
he's not here either well he is just not
out saw Mortal Raiden doesn't get a
flash of light or an animated jello
portal to pop out of it gets nothing
who's the girl can she fight as good as
she looks so is every male character in
this movie gonna make a pass at Jade
right when they meet her destroy
everything
whittany have told her to do this
earlier also her sound wave of
destruction inexplicably stops at our
stories heroes ah that was fun
these two are awfully smug for not
accomplishing anything my god is that
what I think it is yep it's the Golden
Gate Bridge we can never avoid
catastrophe all those cheap booking a
car horn between realms no they're
definitely dead
what no screeching that can destroy
mountains this time just a battle cry
for sake look like this babes having a
bad hair day earn that paycheck Jax I'll
rescue katana I wonder how long it will
take for Raiden to get blasted through a
wall oh right exactly that wall these
guys have the hiding skills of a
three-year-old unnecessary flippin Lu Li
doesn't even try to disguise the fact
that they're just using a stunt double
for ridden yeah oh witness to the
dawning of back times final day the two
wrongs will be one he said it would take
six days but it seems like it only took
at most like 12 hours only the landmark
buildings show up during the movies
proof of realms urging scenes it's a
trap Lou leave katana doesn't tell Lou
this 13 seconds ago okay how is this a
surprise for either of them he was
making so many snorts up there just
before he jumped I bet they get him back
in the earth realm this dude sucks just
because he has a rubber mask on doesn't
make him a badass that could suddenly
hold his own with the guy who keeps
reminding us that he won Mortal Kombat
so was that the trap three hinge men who
were easily defeated and then Shiva who
was squashed by a cage that probably
wasn't that heavy at this point whatever
katana your love can break the hold Kahn
has over your mother mortal kombat
believes in the power of you Lois the
studio owes Disney some money for katana
thinking she's true love's first kiss
her way out of the world being destroyed
you've been tricked the legend was a lie
just like the cake how could you do this
to us yes how could you a complete
stranger that showed up in the desert
for no reason do this to us that tattoo
I've seen it before on a robot and a
woman try saying that three times fast
without laughing
also good thing Raiden decided to change
his entire outfit so that she could see
this huh my father is an elder God funny
how you fail to mention that before
Sonja should know at this point that
important facts are not revealed until
right after something terrible happens
okay I'm adding a hundred sins I don't
think anyone will look Jack
also that girl was just eaten by concept
art for the men in black book you will
mount a defense around my newest temple
take a girl out to dinner first geez
the katana reuniting with her mom thing
was a bust so we are back to Liu has to
defeat Kong even the Liu is the same guy
who definitely could not beat Khan from
before so mental time left I would
submit that there's no time left because
everything seems pretty much destroyed
are we really ready to die here um is
there any other choice the worlds are
nearly merged so you can't just go back
to your apartment don't worry Lu Raiden
will always be with you giving you a
code to control your Dark Passenger
mister add is mine
no one watching this movie would get
that joke I'll take my mother gross
leftovers are fine with me movie doesn't
introduce a Mack earlier in the movie so
now he's just Sonja's leftovers instead
of an actual well-known character like
he is in the games it's also amazing to
me that after sub-zero and scorpion and
reptile the fall back bad guy is only
someone who wears the exact same outfit
only a different color I can't take too
much more this is that all you got these
two lines happen within seconds of each
other you know this is still better than
Sucker Punch and just one look like all
hope was lost everyone got a jolt of
human spirit for some reason Oh Sonya
Sonya just toward that guy to death no
no don't help it the fate of our world
depends on Khan's death but Liu has to
do it himself because I can't explain
why come on if Kahn could animal himself
so quickly why didn't he just do it at
the beginning and kill everyone smoothy
would have been 20 minutes long it
would've been great so the clothes
become dragons too I guess
but they just ripped off like they're
supposed to this would be a very
different movie
I warned you there would be consequences
for breaking the sacred rules but only
now while you're fighting a dude in the
climax of the movie there were no
consequences until then the Mortal
Kombat shouting guy has been waiting in
the wings the whole movie for this
moment also what these for so long they
knew what was going on if they are just
now intervening that anyone can write
this movie or did they just make it up
as they went elder gods still the 2d
prison the Kryptonians used on Zod and
Superman all of these buildings are
restored in their previous stock footage
state katanas mom is back in the real
world living again I guess but all that
bullsh but love had nothing to do with
it I know I'm probably supposed to be
watching this nice family moment between
the discount versions of Terry Crews 90s
Faith Hill Jet Li Salma Hayek and evil
Cicely strong but I just can't quit
grimacing at that penis tower this movie
from 1997 in the days before Harry
Potter made it fashionable has an
incredible
eleven minutes of critics beep Valentin
mother mother Fosse Fosse Fosse you do
Massa Graham Martha Graham Martha Graham
ah he's really showing us what a man
with a cannon in his chest can do you're
all going to die down here
times don't get no better boy gonna
leave this pain take my true love now
you see me now you don't